um secondly uh it looks still um who
Johnson so I've seen
um we splitted and closing on behalf of
um age
um
so you'll need to see it thanks
did you just send that to it's this I
was surprising with it yes
[Music]
is
in many cases yeah
[Music]
um
so what how am I doing
today because have it changed
um
I think it was a single point which I
finally announced sort of notice an
intention that the Autumn went down
towards all of the roots
um I think there are some substance at
the points
internally
if they want to go down below and they
relate to the approach to the
foundations
approach
to a series of
extra policies for the campuses that it
was in deployed over the states
and those sorts of things
okay so tomorrow we will be coming to
spending us this whole world when I've
had a conversation with Mr Hale related
to community now balancing all our
extremely speaking he doesn't need it in
advance I'm going to share with you
well he might need
time concerns
comments
on the council Society
any questions
this one
thank you
for documents I just wanted to say that
this is
my project machine
[Music]
I don't really want them in my house
but what I was going to say is I'm going
to change a little bit I've still had a
weird chance of core documents before
and I think there are some gaps
I just wanted to request you like that
every chance for where we start today
yeah so it's basically
thank you
um I'm just looking at that I'm sure I
saw it I've got the section 106 before
when we get to that
um I'm sure it's also Advanced statement
actually can you just remind me when you
said that because
it's been sentences
thank you
Monday morning
on a specific time
I'm told with a little sense to the
coast officer at Apple Valley
[Music]
foreign
um
next
interview then with our period of
signing on the Masters
so I was going to um
foreign
what sources examples
because
sort of designers
but when we went through all the IEDs
yesterday
I was sure
foreign
[Music]
yes
yeah so in comparing the revised Master
finally supported for this appearing we
saw that there was an opportunity to to
notice even better by ensuring that the
public rights of way became a key there
with them
and so requiring the the MasterCard
University with public rights of way
depending forward the illustrative
perimeter blocks and that's important
because that ensures that stay well
integrated into I've seen a benefit from
active advantages and uh and they're
interest rates of world instantly
proposed development and the less and
illustrates therefore that those public
bikes as we haven't been accommodated on
their precise alignment there's no needs
for any redirections of any public
advice as well my appendix as well
which is called documents
identifies the public right explain how
to turn back and overall over the months
shows so that's the case
without releasing
foreign
[Music]
so those are the actual ones on the
definitive
Maps yes
it's always
the yellow ones
yeah so there's a yellow roots to lose a
pounding sound the Eastern corner of the
site which is is used uh it's not on the
burnt as a map currently what's is well
abused and I think there's proposed
in the future
um
a small area
of dark around it depends on how the
principles sure so so the purple roots
um are Roots there to be used in a wider
context
and so when it just illustrates that
those knocks on the ability
for the rights as well councils but
there that sort of almost patronum
accessible so these highlights of where
where they are accordingly visible
foreign
the appendix 15 you'll see that the
difference is the green colored roots
and that's the green uh where it's just
highlights some additional proposed sort
of paths that we propose to create which
essentially
um follow the alignment of some of the
desire line problem perhaps to make sure
that those connections that already
fixed into the wide important network
are the answers they're just saying that
you know the southern part of the
psychomologists around the surface water
temporalization average
so that not only are the refinances
rights as well you know exchange with
the existing paths that are on the
ground so if we go somewhere so to the
definitive Enterprise
thank you and then if that's political
back to the I think it's the final
illness for the master plan which is
your benefits
at the end
but always ensuring
as well
and I'm sort of generally in order to
speak but whilst we're going to
responding audience
with developed various themes on the
master plan that we were talking about
with certainly were extreme called Green
walks or natural paralyzers
foreign
and
yes
I mean
they didn't want to say on that before
he turns to the secondary topic which is
I think this is
provision I think um
over to some extent yesterday with
Council of foster the visit and there
was a suggested
um
yeah so uh appendix 11 highlights the
state's provision
for the application and deliver
6.72 pack tests in order
and we acknowledge that 1.44
but that's still delivers us five points
you've had 500 ladies take tests
available in space outside of the green
belt with women
so
there's a statement of Common Ground
establishes the public open space
requirements for the site to be 1.57
hectares which is approximately 10
of of the sites area
we provide 40 percent within the
application and obviously where we
provide about three times more open
space
outside of the blue developments
required by a policy so it's a signal
complete amount
whilst while still as we've just
explained yes
we made a statement that we we assumed
with the realistic limits and then we'll
assuming the dwell in the times the
experiences
foreign and we
thought we spoke sometimes
did you prepare those did your firm uh
yes and talked me through this is a
suggestions
there may be participating questions
but yeah I thought it would be useful to
explain the process that uh that we go
through I mean engraves in those those
are just
um so there are a collaboration between
ourselves as the designer uh the Germans
team I'm a run State team as well we
worked together to prepare parents so
personally I wanted landscape colleagues
approached a few points as if they were
preparing landscape visual impacts
assessment so that both the guidance
defined by the landscape Institute
technical guidance notes so the photos
are taken into certain firing millimeter
local one which is regarded as the
closest to the sort of human eye and the
Hines is set at 1.7 retailers and the
positions of those those results are set
up by GPS
3D team
grapes in a 3D model of acceleration
survey survival includes the surrounding
the slopes it might just swing the lower
parts to the side and then using the
auto cap drawings of the examination
areas provided by the journalism
Consultants
actually as well making sure that it's a
model so not always modeling the
gradients of the attenuation analysts
remember in terms of creating that but
alongside in simple terms the existing
viewport viewpoints photos up so they're
imported into their Community software
there's GPS coordinates of the user used
to locate where those photos
of the modeling software to generate the
precise Viewpoint they take three fix
points within the Run state in order to
align as we resilient in the modeling
software
those games then overlays and brought
into their existing workplace devices in
closing shot so everything was all
aligned accurately and as you would
expect them to do so
um yeah it is it's it's based on all the
sort of processes
and it's based on on the organism as
evidence doing by Mr performances
the reason why vision is as they are why
it was because of
the distances
yes
[Music]
anymore
okay
thank you
and Mr Baker I wanted to say to
Elizabeth
I want to learn
so Mr bacon you've already introduced
her assessment
foreign
[Music]
all primarily by uh Mr Thomas
and his assumptions to that
um I think being called what the first
issue that I think is really important
that we need to address is the
mitigation measurement so
um the original ecological assessment
that was produced in 2018
didn't have the benefits of the
compensation motion surprised in the
articles in their game Frozen
so the assessment
sometimes in 2018 uh
[Music]
certain amount of damage we've not been
able to be
addressed but of course that has now
changed because the BMG
proposals have been have been brought
forward so that does change the a
settlement in typically
those
loss of Pedros was the second chapter
yes there was a there was a description
of the Petro's team of Highly valued
um now that that statement isn't correct
um and my mum I'd draw your attention to
the assessment uh
um
that's set out in CV
1.0.20
at Team uh this is a paragraph number is
3.16 where the headphones are assessed
um and just an example are about one
point Sorry paragraph one one two the
headquarters are described it and I
quote the head but the heterozan species
poor and unmanaged when they're likely
to Bringing support programs species per
Hedge
so that is that is what uh and if I look
in terms of evaluation we would say that
was a species board ultra
um
statements
yes so going on there's no denial that
that hendrons will be lost to the to the
development
um and that has been addressed in the
biodiversity Net game proposed on
and you'll see from the calculations
that we have put forwards that being
Bean key proposal will generate
128.8 percent gaining portable drones
now
uh just bearing in mind that that's
again
so 10 again and it's waters are busy by
the forthcoming
CLG legislation which I've John Beltran
but that's a whole King's one space it's
an ordered by one two across um
yes
[Music]
uh there's been quite a lot of nurses in
the evidence of the hydro regulations
and I just wanted to put that into a bit
of context
um
but my background nowadays is I do a lot
of work on uh my expertise as a marriage
conservation law I spend most of my time
in one legally related and
um
[Music]
interpretation of multiple conservation
law the headline reps were introduced
primarily to the top pages but worms
going to come through the timing process
in terms of
[Music]
should be considered under the uh under
the regulations
um
most of the criteria for that are
non-eatological related so they're
related to the number of connections the
presence of
a hetero band
um
structural Criterion there is one
criteria which looks the species persons
within the Headroom
now only two of the hedgerows in within
the site actually qualify an ecological
grounds and that's purely because of the
presence of legal
um
and you can see that assessment at the
end of the ecological
reports and it goes through each of the
hobos in the public settlement
now that isn't
a an assessment of the ecological
problem of those headphones there's
purely a trigger whether it be
Hydrox Supply now
because the headboard Rex was really put
together to stop the removal of
headrooms outside the planning system
there is a clause within the
um uh within the breaks which means that
uh essentially one kind of admission is
granted in fact which be the chemist
then the requirements of assessment
under the head members all as well
so just in summary the important thing
in mind being I mean since the
legislation is that we should assess the
ecological value of the headphones in a
place like this
uh that assessment has been carried out
yes micros will be lost for those role
where we're delivering
as I've said earlier 128 gain in terms
of headphones
so that structurally function of those
had those within the area will be
maintained within the development in
fact it might be will be enhanced
because of the level of address that the
number of headphones that will be
introduced
I'm just finally
the
indicative design for the science
has
has retained as many headphones
within the components as possible
so they've been very careful to make
sure that as many of those headphones
are high return
s
so that's assessment I presume that
Assessments in terms of impacts on
health headphones was carried out at the
um allocation stage
impact on birds
yes and this is this is a an interesting
one but Mr Thompson has has learned that
there is data has been gathered on uh
Birds on the site I've not seen that
data I don't know being Collectibles I
don't know what their qualifications
were so I can't really assess what the
uh what the level or importance of the
species that we have recorded on site
um
[Music]
the ecological assessment
uh at a table 20
does set out the value of the uh the
birds that were recorded on site and
they were all recorded as being as local
local value now just put that in context
in terms of value we have a hierarchy of
value uh starting with site by the local
value then County value and then
reaching
so the bird's recorded on site were all
considered to be a local bunny
and
I think it was also a comparison made
with pattern Hall
um
and
I think the the approach was well have
we all recorded similar number of birds
within the environment
again we've not seen that data uh I
don't know how it was collected I don't
know how many surveys were about or what
were certainly effort was and
[Music]
um
it just doesn't make any sense at all
so I think this is this is important in
terms of adverbs
the habitats that will be created
including the hydros will more than
compensate in the structure and function
of this area of land for the birds
species
so I would expect given the level of
compensation that's being put forward is
that that structure and culture will be
maintained and the third populations
will remain unaffected and may even
benefit actually from The increased
density of heterose that will be
introduced next door to the problem
or anticipating a question that will be
continuing by your instructor because
I think there was some
response was given the amount over these
things or only development parts of
their science in terms of living foreign
have been designed to be as
so we assign value to specific habitats
um and there is a certain amount of
interpretation that is within the metric
in terms of for example a setting the
value of the habitats that will be
created down further down the line so
there is some interpretation of that
when doing those assessments
um so for example
we don't necessarily assume that the
that newly created grasslands will be of
High
um uh let's age good condition that we
also the process we generally we
generally assume that it's going to be
moderate condition
um but at the end of the day the process
is formulated uh we have crunched the
numbers as it were based on the areas
but I think the difference here is that
many signs that we look at are
um popularity around the chance is very
low value
in this case we're looking at pasture
Urban and pasture land which has a
higher starting value
so I think that's probably where the
main you know
the difference is with other science is
that this is passed around and we're
starting with a higher if you want to be
currently than the person
s
yes
um I think Mr Thompson has stated that
there is an hour or WS local bar graph
site with all the development and there
isn't that's not the case
um
um and that is people gay
which will be retained and will be
managed for wildlife scenario calculus
grassland which is currently I probably
scrubbed over there's quite a lot of
scope and creation of material and
um with any with any uh Landscaping
ecology management plan what what would
be proposed to manage that calculations
so we don't have an impact on local
wildlife
seaweed bottom left corners
for the last time
I was
absolutely instructions
[Music]
thank you enough
um
yeah
[Music]
foreign
um my name is Paul Johnston I'm the
chair of killer Marsh residency against
Green Belt Road uh rage for short
um my qualifications are that uh I am an
ex-protective chief of weekends that I
can read less about it as far as
planning is concerned
rage are all local residents they're not
Nimbus but we are concerned about the
consequences for all residents of killer
March particularly those living in
proximity to this proposed side
due to the many varied challenges
associated with the site we actually
know the locality and do not have to
learn about it from Whistle Stop tours
or desktop studies and yes we're
challenging the rationale on this side
being elevated in the local plan
once adopted in the local plan a
specific site then has to fulfill the
specific requirements of policy
the answer the cliff highlighted a
number of these challenges
um and talked about the 5 000 new homes
either newly built partially built a
width planning permission a short
distance from killer March some 3 000 of
these within three miles of the
kilometers boundary
this should help the alleged high demand
for houses in killer Marsh
even though it's not actually the camera
margins in the area
he also pointed out that the newly
opened Gulliver's Valley Park only one
mile come to the marsh has planning
permission for three hotels with 1600
car parking spaces all of which will
have an attack on tour of mass traffic
I also spoke of this sustainable
development myth surrounding this site
which pales all three of the nppf tests
economic economic benefits will not fall
in killer March neither will the
requirement to locate and it was a a
mistake on my document there it says
development but it means employment
opportunity is close to where people
live
um that's the aspiration of the local
plan
the full protected employment sites are
all unsuitable for reasons of age
evacuidation capacity or expansion
potential this will enforce our
community when coupled with an
unsustainable transport plan as our
presented evidence shows
no Financial benefit will accrue from
either new development opportunities or
new homes bonus money due to the
Strategic priorities of the local plan
being elsewhere in the district
neither proximate nor relevant to kill a
marsh
the social aspect fails because the
facilities of killer Marsha cried away
from the site and assertion supported by
presented evidence
the area of Green Space former Greenbelt
plan is part of the local Recreation
officer with private public writing ways
Crossing it please give delightful views
which I hope you will see to the South
and Western being for your side
we heard this morning that large areas
of Green Space will be retained this
isn't in but it's based on what I've
heard this morning
um will be large Wildlife areas to the
there to the North and the South West of
the site the bottom left and the top
right
um
it's strange that these areas are the
ones where contamination from polycytic
aromatic type recoverments are located
and where gas escaped in the north one
have been found as well but these are
the wildlife sites have been retained
um the doctor patient ratio of the
killer March Medical Practice is
operating at a doctor patient ratio of
almost three times the district average
this will be exceeded if this
development is built section 106 Melissa
thought will be distributed into poor
surgeries in the locality with one not
in Illinois being shown as high Aid
the money for other surgeries including
kilimarsh May well be diluted to this
election needed to the marshes by far
the highest housing allocation of the
tier one town
the local dental surgery has not been
accepting new patients for many years
to accept that the local schools have
the spatial capacity to accept new
pupils although this is only one aspect
of school admissions parental choice is
an issue with two with two of the four
feeder schools having challenging of
state reports
the killer Marshall from school which is
good will feel in the Junior School
which isn't
it's received two requires Improvement
ratings in its last two offspend visits
the secondary school of technician is in
special measures
this means that parents will look to
place their children elsewhere which
involves more use private cars pollution
and travel at a good time
the school with the least space is the
closest to the development
the environmental impact of this
assessment will be katast and I've just
heard what Mr Baker said of the Ecology
of the site
uh he talked about the Haddon medieval
Park and this is something that's freely
available on the internet about these
survey of birds that were there
the park found 58 different species of
birds with 12 on the red and dangers
live
that's in 187 acres of land oh sorry 187
hectares
excuse me
Illinois site has 66 paintings with 15
on the regulars the red and dangerous
this was in 17.1 acres of hectares I'm
sorry
functional Greenway will be lost and
replaced by one alongside the main road
Alan with you spoke about the errors
reports within the sustainable transport
plan proposed by Neapolitan shuttled by
foot or cycle is not a viable option as
agreed by inspector housing due to the
site's location of the edge of the
settlement some two kilometers from
facilities
the bus service was the lowest of the
Tier 1 towns in the sustainability
assessment and there are many errors in
the document in terms of route and
service provision as out buying
with evidence of topography and
difficulty provided by Mr Whitaker
the unviable policy will engine the
significant car use in addition to the
almost 2 000 daily additional trips
suggested by the appellant
much evidence outlined with photographic
evidence the power state of the killer
Marsh roads particularly in relation to
the proposed sign
the identified pinch points where
traffic would be stored because of
private part private vehicles with
nowhere else below the Strategic
transport issues report describing the
new roses having cool links to the
Strategic Network and indicates that the
roads of Chesterfield the M1 and the
cell if we contested by having tried to
get here this morning again as minor
roads
Stephen Thompson described the Ecology
of the site including the need to
protect existing trees Woodland and
hedge roads uh for their immediate value
he stressed the need to protect trees
and hedge roses or development
permission would be refused and referred
to the Head drugs on the site all
passing in the 30-year longevity
requirement to be protected by
behavioral regulation we just heard from
Mr Baker on that inspector
um Mr Mr Baker said that these were not
uh important uh hedgerows the the access
ecology report in 2018 said that there
were there were ecologically important
hedgerows of more than 140 years old
based on their evidence
it seems like if you don't like what uh
what one experts only primed another one
who will change that
that might not be fair to Mr Baker
yeah
they said they won't be politically
brought into it
um
some of the Hedge roads are identified
as ecologically important being more
than 150 years old the environmental
impact assessment for this side shows
that the loss functionality and
structure will mean that there is no
longer a functional green Network across
the side it will be replaced as you
heard by uh one beside the roadway the
main East West Columbia side
it also referred to the loss of 70 of
the semi-improved grassland including a
wildflower Meadow uh Cube Garden has
reinforced the importance of wildfire
Wildflower Meadows for soil stability
and the landscape's value in absorbing
rainwater Mr Thompson referred to the
local Wildlife sites approximately
appeal time being affected by this
development and its equivalent to a
better provision philosophical issues
should be available and uh should should
be available equivalent in quantity and
quality and should be available prior to
the loss in accordance when the policy
ID 10.
habitats will be lost and there is no
mitigation for such laws
councilor Eva Thompson outlines her
evidence her in evidence the concerns
about biodiversity and the loss of sight
uh the last of the site is informal
Recreation space she airs her concerns
about the site's mining Legacy of
details her survey of local schools
sharing concerns expressed by one school
about congestion the school crossing
point outside school and worries about
Road Safety if you go there about 3 15
today inspector outside the uh or
between the infant and the Union School
where you'll see the chaos that then
snooze
Brady Mahoney was concerned about the
air quality assessment of the site which
was very late in being provided and
which did not appear to cover traffic
pinchpoint congestion in the vicinity of
the site with the resultant emissions
from stationary idling traffic or a main
Junction on Springfield Road which
Junction with upper Thorpe Road where
the junction is on an incline where
idling traffic might create pollution
we live on that Junction and I can
attest to that
she was also concerned that the many
challenges of the cycling question had
not been subjected to a requirement of
an environmental impact assessment she
provided evidence to support the
researching
Claire Cooper expressed her concern at
the visual Narrative of the gap between
killer Marsh and Springfield caused by
the 43 meter dropping elevation leaving
the site clearly in view from the
direction of Springfield
this closes the Gap there's a visual
inclusion into the countryside with the
Westport Creole business park being
totally invisible from this location
which is the only place where the site
can be overlooked
the only way that this is overlooked
near the college you can see the fields
of the sides when you can't see this the
West Brookfield business park at all
counselor Wendy Tinley unfortunately now
confirmed with covid refers to the
potential archaeological importance of
the Westfield side with the
investigations potentially finding a
medieval Holloway a ring ditch which is
a form of burial ground and a building
potentially from Creek history
these are in locations which would have
building over them on the indicative
plan
many other potential crimes are
indicated from scans of the land
councilor Alex Platts outlined his
appears for increased flooding in the
site locality showing pictures of recent
historical events and expressing
concerns of the removal of soil and the
one for Wildflower Meadow could affect
ground stability and drainage by
concrete replacing soil which would
affect the ground water absorption
capability
counselor Chris Curtin outlines his
objectives for the removal the original
historical locations and allocating
routes on payments standard support
stands supported by and representative
Accenture the local Ramblers Association
I appreciate the point that the
representative of senator may have been
looking at an older plan inspector
um and I want to just cover that in my
my pros and cons
Mr Curzon claimed that he and neighbors
had a legal right of access having
fulfilled the requirement uh sorry the
requisite news qualification and that
they had also had a right of access to a
legal easement by prescription
which would prevent part of the site
being developed in accordance with the
current individual plan
Mr Chris Broadhead returned to the
mining Legacy of Messiah the challenging
remediation costs and the possibility of
the site viability being questionable
uh this was actually in the first design
and access payment it was actually
questioned by the representative
representing Iran Howard has stated
about time
um
previous representations
it was greatly concerned because the
conditional acceptance of the current
application by the UK coal Authority
came from incomplete records although
closing closing one known Mineshaft of
the five known to be on site to be found
not to become sorry this was exacerbated
by the unknown Coral exploitation
activities which are evidenced by the
unrecorded workings of the shallow
seeing on site leaving made ground on
the service service he highlighted that
authorized remediation issue sorry he
highlighted authorized remediation did
not necessarily mean a risk-free side
filing highlighting a specific
instrument close to the appeal site
inspector in closing and I would like to
give thanks to you specifically for your
uh fair-mindedness in allowing me to uh
to give this this closing statement on
behalf of range as you're fully aware
there's been a tsunami of documents in
relation to this application
871 of the latest count
um and 250 placed on in the last two
weeks some of it repetitious of course
we have been lay people navigating the
Minefield of prime law and case law
which you are only too familiar with
with Hudson help and support from the
parish just from some Parish district
and County councilors none from the
district Authority frankly they're
cowardly what I they're my words
decision not to support their planning
committee and their one will they
witness with expert advice is
not acceptable
local advice suggests uh that uh sorry
legal advice suggested that the council
should to use yes uh array to use
yesterday fall on their thought in
respect of all the uh all the grounds of
appeal but that's legal advice as I
understand it suggested that they obtain
more evidence before doing that that
wasn't them
officers are not challenged
um
the a lot of the uh the proposals from
Howard that had an 11-year association
with Harwood because that's when raid
was born 11 years ago when we were told
that the site was inevitably going to be
built on and uh or we could do was after
what was put on it
Regis formed as a result of that to try
and find that proposal I'm not
suggesting any impropriety at all I'm
suggesting
um when rage have found and documented
anomalies uh that the council should
have been Earth in my view a new expert
or a plan or a desktop study has been
spent in by the fund because they have
the ability to do naturalization and the
wealth to do that
no one has looked after the Health and
Welfare issues that's appear to be
associated with this application
thank you for allowing me to uh to speak
and thank you for your time
very welcome thank you
foreign
okay
um can we then look at the conditions
festivals
or would you rather do you legal
agreement do you mind if we do the legal
agreement first okay
um
there's a reason for my request and
that's it that um
determines the the language of the uh of
the documents is agreement
but we just need to do a quick stop on
the plan on the back right and it'll
take a little bit of time brought out
signatures and one of the opportunities
particular trees is in the council to
them and then the next one will be next
Thursday and unconscious concerned that
it's the day before Good Friday and I
want to try and get a closer to you
again as soon as we're happy with
document so a little fun spots needed so
that would mean I can walk away today
with them into glue to the queen
you know because
the document still has to be um not just
the council but several other part is
going to need to sign apparently they
have to sign the plan as well okay so
when do you believe you don't have a
final copy
well ordinarily I want to start a week
but I think with Easter stuck in the way
it's it's one of those opportunities
where you can almost guarantee there'll
be a couple of days and actually when
somebody won't be available
um and maybe even a couple of days a
week now but
so
fortnight
I mean yeah
um
so by the 14th
I'll wait for it
the process today that one of the
signatures we see but there are lots of
others that need management
I for some reason I feel I have a final
copies
it's agreements
you can take it as bad
um and the plan is what will be very
minor but needs to be done okay
okay um 14th of April very
um
being expecting any delay beyond that
before you won't be any of these
decisions
yeah I think subject to any comments
that you have on the document now
you will be able to take away the text
as a final thing okay
that is confirmed
thank you
okay
um shall we run through it then
did you see the um
uh the summary names
it doesn't continue with the one I'm
says
um
is it all page note which
is what it does yeah it stops US it
gives us the references of where each
point is but it's not designed to click
back and forth in the document to
cross check definitions and things on
um
I hope that's helpful and let me know if
you wanted to sort of
memorize your work crew though
it's been it's agreement
yeah I think um this brought me through
it then because it would be more
familiar than you it's great
[Music]
um
the the first thing um important to me
that it doesn't deal with affordable
housing
um I'm running on the on the summary
mode
the amount of affordable housing is 20
of the dwellings so that's however many
dwelling of whether it's 397 or what
ever 20 percent
a tenure location size and mix
has to be submitted and agreed with
cancer
and the construction of them has to be
in accordance with the planet commission
including Reserve matters
and then there's a delivery mechanism
which is
um
identify the
registered provider
enter into a contract with the
upon occupation of 30 of the market
housing
um
if there hasn't been
a registered provider entered into the
contract to acquire
and there's a notification to the
council
Council can then nominate to registered
provider of its own
um and those properties will be marketed
to that for the party
dictionary nomination
30 games
collected to revert to an artery of its
own choosing
and use the reasonable endeavors
to contract to transfer the rented and
the shared ownership units
which together comprise the affordable
housing
there's a there's a Cascade mechanism as
there there are division of this sort of
Arrangements because in the event that's
um or maybe all
of the affordable housing units are not
taken forward
by a race provider then it reverts to a
an amount of money
in which we've seen if you turn the
summary document to the second page
halfway down
equates to 45 of the market value of
each of the affordable units
um that's looking into some bed
um and that's how
that delivery mechanism for the
affordable units works
then the next part of the 106 is
essentially a series of financial
contributions and the um
the approach to those has been failed
already in the evidence
um although some of the numbers are
slightly different to how they were in
the committee report
and the reason for that I understand is
because in relation to
um
in particular health
there is a new figure in the standard
formula that is being used before
management derives from the
infrastructure delivery time endorsed by
the local time inspection part of that
process
there is an update in the course days of
construction
and obviously at least the is type and
then across basically from time to time
up for example it's the latest iteration
I think
there's still complaint statement
um
I'm not the author of that that's
Council documents now I wouldn't I
wouldn't say concerning
um
snugging
that lives without sense
in section 106 it's a dwelling
contribution
it's it's probably worth just looking at
the way the contributions work because
some of them are fixed amounts and some
of them have heard dwelling amounts yeah
so the first contribution of working of
the summary is legal things obviously it
was a fixed demand
um
County legal fees
monitoring payment fixed amount County
monitoring payments fixed amount
um
the affordable housing communities that
I alluded to earlier that's as if there
are no arcings that take some or any of
the properties that's 45 of the market
value so that's lots of fixed amount
it's her affordable unit
that isn't taken through the intended
first channel of disposal
um so if they won't get picked up you
make a contribution
um and it's 45
of the market value of the affordable
units that haven't been disposed onto an
art being from this point investment
the next is the additional first homes
contribution
which is a calculation again I reference
to the number of dwellings
the next is the cricket information
District
foreign
contributions I think we've covered
affordable housing
I mean
we've written in uh councils
thank you
the first total of today is a sort of
part of the affordable housing
it's also an additional file
everything
is on page 12 of the actual 106.
audible the first home was the
affordable housing event to be provided
um as first homes
so it's it's a sub part of
not International
foreign
homes to be provided
um by or two
Freehold or in case of flats which I
think is better going to arrive but if
it does a long range hold
it's about exhaust
um
at a price
uh tapped in accordance with guidance
published by the department for leveling
up Etc in 1921 so it's simply another
route into affordable housing
yeah it is effective with discount
Market yeah but that was the first time
so we still can help me out here there's
still compliance statements basically
telling me there's a policy in the late
families those 20 affordable housing
General
support we're securing
20 affordable housing
what's the solution of plans payment
how does that work it's not additional
it's part of what if it's not
nice
and it operates the
as a market discount
um fixed in accordance with government
guidance yeah
well forgive me there's still complaint
Spence there's nothing about it
let me explain that
but if that I have just not seen it
before it's their official first-hand
contribution
the lower the volunteer now 30 for their
amounts but I don't seem justified
performing in the open times thing
videos
um it was it's in the agreement as an
option like a way of like contributions
towards the 2017 affordable housing kind
of policy itself isn't coverage or
um
consequences
okay
um
as one of the options in the the
mechanisms
you know when the student comes in it's
decided but
part of what's provided one of the first
time it's the section 106 provides for
that
I mean that's that sounds fine when he's
back with their people it's not
like that
so as I understand it
100 affordable housing if you can't
you know provided to take them on and
then you'll pay 45 of the market value
for them I mean they'll say there's
caveaters some of them are first payment
you pay some money as well
India real life I think I think that's
the drift of it right
um
I think the first time was something
that in the negotiation of this we
um
if they can come back to the first poems
in a bit more detail in the agreement
but I'm just going to sidestep to
another point
if there is just something you're aware
of it
um
page 24 of the of the document
um what I think is commonly referred to
as a blue pencil test oh yeah I'm
familiar with that even just so that
you've got that yeah if there's any bits
of it that you don't like yeah well
that's you know what I'm just trying to
figure is have I got the information
before me to justify
these obligations in this local client
statement yeah I think
you can turn to page 113 it would be
106.
you'll see Philistines are dealt with
yeah construction
delivery delivery including stale
sailing a particular way eligible
criteria
and the point that I think you're asking
about which was the
and the amount of money the lower the
two amounts point it was in the summary
is where you get to if you can't deal
with them in a similar way to the final
layout point in the other affordable if
you can't get read
then there is a capsule that is a
monetary capsule right
okay
and is there anything to support how the
money sheer amounts have been
all right yeah back to the council
has come back to that yep
if we
go back to the summary in terms of the
other contributions the cricket pitch
according to within two parts one is for
works the other install maintenance
um
Healthcare contribution that has
directly occurred Welling
and it derives from the latest
um calculation coming out in the
protocol and the thing that's going to
delivery plan with the latest figures in
what I mentioned earlier
and it's it's worked out or capable of
it being worked out per dwelling in the
new multiplied by the number that there
are yeah
and the playing pitch contributions very
much like the theory
let's just work through them one by one
yeah just to see if I've got that
information that I need when I'm writing
it up
did you want to say any more about how
things have been calculated for being
affordable housing can lead to some or
the official first payments contribution
I don't see it and I still can find the
statement
and relative directly to it
um I'm not at the moment that's why this
one's a difficult time hey all right
all right okay so
okay
[Music]
so this was basically being to write a
cricket pitch at the last email at 6 30.
basically hit something
like we're asking yourself Explorer
[Music]
how gross 3.9 onwards yeah
3.12 okay
now is a referred to the bully though is
not there
so I guess we're still compliant
statement is asking me to take its word
about that information
well I think it's appendix behave we've
got the formula thank you it doesn't say
that I'm still confident in your
statement
it seem like Texas
so that's going to appendix five if it's
manager made of that
yes please hoping I'll give you the
inquiry trying to piece this together
you know
and it's five yeah
specific to this language well it's an
email that's got it's got the
calculation in okay the origin of the of
the members in the nation is um
thank you
so in gospel England calculations for
how much of credit you're going to cost
you 55
or a thousand yeah
and then we've got the life cycle cost
I was like translated with that in a
convict five as well
yes one yeah
what's your contribution then the word
is that comes wrong
but some think is the details
um and which sport do you have the
council document
so
the next story is um
is identified as a highways points in
the list of appendices
on the Silicon blind statement
um appendix 4 has the calculator which
is the standard calculator for the
health yeah thank you
um and it has a email
who sue rate but just advised the
increasing costs which you can build
cost increase from
2400 to 4500 this device the difference
between the figures
so that's the difference between the
figures
um
at the time of the committee reports the
cost per dwelling was 480 pounds 24.
yeah the cost per dwelling now is 900
pound and she's 45. yeah
um and that email we will understand
that we've
foreign
ER calculator and then there is an email
um commissioned right from uh Joanna
dated 7th of March
yeah
so it says 2400 to 4500
which is the calculator and turn over to
the third page yeah there is a a tabular
nature that can identifies additional
patients at 993 which aligns with the
evidence the standard area 0.08 and then
the third one is this 4 500 with an
asterisk saying updated lay 22 in Bill
cross which is what that email does that
calculates the total figure for clearly
we break it back to a cost per dwell in
business in Fortune
um in the description
um
so if you say 4 500 is it costs like
learning but the 4 500 is is the cost
which is identified but that's not the
section 106 contribution right yes
that's right so it's on the way sorry
the way this formula is in base is that
yes it's a build cost to enhance the
healthcare provision based upon a
formulaic approach of how many patients
what size that would translate into uh
floor space what the bill costs in the
public sector would be to deliver that
that gets to a figure either 4500 is
a square meters
and then worked out February the NHS has
in this standard so there is a developer
contribution protocol
um which is produced by the council by
the district sorry County Council which
is one of your core documents that's the
basic of the calculation that the County
Council bring forward they have this
standard formula which will justify and
have evidence of being appropriate in
line with the
um local time evidence base and what
they have taken the opportunity to do
between the uh committee and now is
update that base build cost which is
nearly double really fun
in other words
um the calculation starts with 397 loans
it says that equates to 993 patients
it then applies the amount of space per
patient which is a point to zero eight
square meters so it obviously reduces
the number right now
it then multiplies by the build cost per
square in each one that's the figure
that's gone
it's called 4 500 with square meter from
2400.
report
it comes to a total now
um 3574
and then that is divided back by the
number of 397 dwellings and that's where
the 900 comes from and
this is the biggest change with the
amount of dwelling
to please have to do list allows you to
address that no because as we've got
1500 per dwelling which is the end of
this calculation with all the new
numbers in
to a per dwelling figure
then it is that per dwelling 377
times that's why you've done it then
yeah if it's
397 dwelling then it's yeah 397 times
900 ounces
there was a label this but it is just
worth noting the the current serving
this on the health and there's a
document that's part of being exposure
to Mr Robinsons that says yeah we can
see that there is stress at the closest
GT surgery in terms of being
patient GP ratio
but there isn't there isn't in the in
the in the group
so it's a location Point rather than so
it's a micro location rather than actual
location overall the Health Group
so
that may need a bit of thought not to do
with the calculation than the origin of
the numbers
but on the principle right thank you
Mr Wallace and reminds me this is about
anyway Thursday's Healthcare statement
with that group
you remember another playing pitch
bring June pitch
an all-weather surface
playing pitch
l City councils justification for it you
know it's back to them again
it's the very last page of a thing that
well there are only two layers a lot of
pagans don't explain
the PBS action code
on the project used in those which the
applications over we're not actually
told where
uh as to the last thought something
that's all well that's actually the most
important she can't say there is a
better project though
confused with the concatenation and
cultural policy methodology
found it
demand calculator translation
so it's very shortly
these sort of language
well
um
there was a flight in the supply so it
was identify being elected one so
um
identity climbing or oxide
I think
that what is your id10 that's going to
tell me how it's been hydrated and
respect to this appeal specifically
where the money will be and how it's
been calculated
yes
um what part of the other day tomorrow
is
statute time oh that's what yeah it's
actually kind of so where is that is
that attached to leave appendix
um it's not in touch within companies
um
okay sounds really I mean
easy to navigate
can they get a cool document number
so that I can find this in two or three
weeks time when I'm writing it up and
remembering this conversation
yeah
we translate
it really should be in the all in the
self-employment statement it's still
compliance statements there's supposed
to say
justifying it where's the policy support
how you calculated specifically where
it's going and why it's going there
because there's an identified needs
I'm not sure there's still compliance
though with doing that before me
well I'm not sure it's doing that for
the 3G pitch I'm not sure it's giving up
for the cricket coach
um
I know you've got your own point
it is vitally important to justify
consecutions because we have to meet
certain tests
in order to accept obligations and
applying commission we have
we satisfied and I have to be specified
they need those tests too
otherwise they just get scrapped so
they're very important
can't just ask somebody and not justify
it when asking when granting planning
patient now start seen as paying for
planning permissions virtually
okay
did I carry on or
I mean I'm happy I realize these are
probably very painful for everybody
watching but um
do you want me just to take the still
compliance statement or should we keep
going through and seeing what's missing
and trying to add to it
I think you need to run I think I think
you need to interrogate the Council of
justification for the obligations well I
can do that at home I've got the still
compliance statement yeah but if you've
got this missing
really at this stage I should be walking
away with this this was raised by the
case management conference very early on
statements
I mean they come up every single time
okay let's have a quick look at
education
um
but is it your special education
there's a board looking now
the 106 and the evidence is that there
is only special education needs there's
nothing for primary there's nothing
wrong so it is
the only one
according to the preparations of
dhcca contributions protocol
is there anything more on that
foreign
um
who can say no no well we'll turn this
to be
um
garbage councils development Contracting
which means protocols right okay where's
the good opportunity reference in
there's still compliance there so that I
may navigate things
when trying to work out how you
calculated do you think
would it be worth me saying this is just
a suggestion that perhaps the council
take this away and
revise it and make it a bit more user
friendly and then we could have that
you know it can be circulated I think
that's a very good idea
um I think you you need to jump from
person you need to know the record
documents and what they are and where
they are yeah exactly
I need to be able to get if I haven't
done that information to satisfy these
tests
so that we can
I can effectively authorize these
obligation
um let me just
you know just to tell you what is needed
from
being myself
I will require a pretty detailed
justification for any obligation it's
something out perhaps implies you just
feel regulating and particular tests but
most definitely I encouraging to get the
harm rising out of the development page
Financial contribution exactly how it
has been calculated and on precisely
what it would be spent
okay but that is in
years CNC life
so are you happy you can do that for me
and if you're referring to something
like
PC has been
reported or whatever
um make sure acronyms are explained and
if I have to go somewhere else to say
the calculation
provide that
at least a reference to it if not an
appendix
or just put it in this building homeless
baby so there would be ideal
I want to set a deadline for that
because there's no reason yeah
so just for arguments say let's call it
the Friday
um so 7th of April
yeah is that okay with your parents just
looking right up for that yeah I mean
it really is for the council to justify
the points we've we've done the 106 to
reflect those just those points but
I can I can talk you through what the
106 does but it's up to them
yeah I realize it's more of an account
for which one
okay let's show that for a moment and
we'll say we'll get successful
compliance statement but we'll do what
it needs to do and then I can reveal
with that outside of the inquiry channel
are you happy yeah I'm happy with that
um
just simply the mechanism for first
homes because we talked about the first
first homes in terms of mechanism and
talked about themselves justification
I'm not speaking to justification but in
terms of mechanism
what what might be useful just to make a
quick notice page 12
of the 106 defines first homes
as the affordable housing units to be
uh Donald's first home so that's the
first day was our sub part of being
audible okay
um
then
it's worth just keeping a notice of
what's on page 13 as the definition of
first holes sales private via
and
um that sets up the mechanism or their
delivery
and the first home's contribution is on
page four
and that's in the circumstances where
the first homes haven't been provided
and it's the
I think sometimes called like a spiral
out or the sort of the commuted some
option
so it's it's a bit like the provision of
affordable housing to an RP
that doesn't get taken up by the RP
what's the sale of first homes on terms
that make them affordable that then
don't get taken up and what happens next
and that was the contribution point that
you were looking at in the in the
summary names exactly
that's the mechanism of it that's the
gist of it
that's the word and there is a
justification the first owns as a subset
affordable housing
across the table
thank you
um yeah okay are we going to need a
further section on this at some some
points I don't know but uh the sexual
nice day
um I hope not be concerned I wouldn't
exist each one for the Practical point I
made earlier
I'm now behind Keen to get into
execution signing into meeting
yeah well no all we're talking about
your big principles of course we'll deal
with and so I think you've been push on
me yes I mean then whatever I put in the
decision world through the blue pencil
clause
financially
yeah so it won't delay you and I don't
think we need another session I think
the council have had adequate
opportunity to justify
um the obligation
um obviously they've got another week to
do that but if nothing is coming well
you know I'll have to take it at that
point whether I have something or
whether I don't I want them Christine to
look at the tests but those obligations
and then um it will be the 13-month
decision
okay
um
can we move on to conditions then
yes Mom
so we've got something we just used and
others agree
yes well the inquiry reference inquiry
document reference I think that you'll
need is ID one and then it would be
helpful I think also if you have the
you know the
um transport statement of case
which a common ground sorry which is
called document reference 3.3.3
um that's in respect to the dispute
information yes indeed artel public
church and I just talk you through where
we've got to and what you've got in
front of you would that be helpful yes
please yeah so uh mum we work closely
with the local Authority and within id1
you have um as you rightly say the list
of agreed conditions and then you have a
schedule of conditions that are not
agreed if I just explain the broad
principles of those that are not agree
as as two parts
um the first part is two conditions
whereby they relate to the green belts
and they relate to the sustainable Earth
and drainage basins and the difference
between the two parties I think can be
characterized about whether those the
additional information within the
conditions that the appellant brings
forward is necessary okay so sorry
backtrack a little bit inquiries to see
are we here we will be I was just giving
you the overview and then something you
understood if that would help so so
there's two conditions related to that
um and we've engaged with the Council on
the precise wording so it's a more a
matter of principle around that which
we'll come back to in detail and and
then the second group of conditions
um relate to a very contestant that are
contested yeah they relate to highways
um and again there is no difference
between us on the necessity for the
conditions it's the precise wording and
the precise impossibility yeah um I've
got Mr Blair with me to just to help
talk through those because he engaged
with the County Council so I'm in your
heart your hands real if you want to go
through the non-contested first uh up to
you really I mean no one could be tested
I must admit with the fact that we've
had relatively full days I haven't
looked at these outside of them inquiry
time but UK well I might have long days
and I haven't had a chance to look at
them they're uncontested
um
I mean let's have a quick
click through and see if everything
jumps off the page but can I just have
General grieving that
um if little tweets can leaders and um
implementation causes and that sort of
thing that you're happy for me to make
it's a point now
um but essentially they agreed between
you let's just run I'll run through them
quickly just like I say see if an
example of the page but with the caveat
that um I haven't looked at them before
now and um
generally if something is going off I
think I always deal with that in an
email separately between those parts of
you as well let's have a quick look
Intel group state number one details of
access yeah clearly we don't need that
because that's being agreed right so
it's got in Brackets other than points
of access so yeah so what we're having
agreeing here
um is it's the location not the detail
let me go to something even
so it's where they are I think it did
you heard the evidence
um around the precise geometry is yet to
be agreed right and reserved matter
stage hence it's kept within Reserve
matters but we are
um implemented part of the application
element is that we know where those
access points are
right I thought we had plans today you
do mum in condition two
um are the plans to be approved and
those
um are listed at the bottom of that
first page which are the plans so just
explain to me why
because it's the location of the access
points rather than before you today the
precise geometry of those access
ES
oh it's got the location of them but not
the precise geometry it's important
about I think in um the chronology of
what happens so there were detailed
plans for all three accesses
um reasonably shortly before the
planning committee
uh the County Council the highway
Authority said we're happy with the
principle we're happy with the locations
but the detail of those and Junctions
isn't quite how we would like it so it
was settled at the time but the matter
was caught to the council or
determination but over the location
rather than the detail on the drawings
would be approved
geometry Radiance all of that okay and
what I would normally do with that then
is rather than call it a reserve matter
I just have a think of saying I want
these things
from my perspective yes
and if it gives you any comfort mom the
County Council statement of Common
Ground what Mr Blair has done is carry
on those discussions and we know what
the answer is they don't just were not
part of the process for the reasons Mrs
Davis said so there's no doubt about it
doesn't really difficult
for illustrative purposes they're
actually appended to the statement of
common ground on highways with a
that will be what is submitted to the
terms of this condition
and we know that it works
um are you happy for me to draft that
question if it's not call the reserve
matter
um this one it's something that asked
for we can tell
yeah basically retail about expecting
approved in writing yes
and we've got pretty plans which
we've been checking details
my location
and sold in relationships
singing slowly in relation to location
yeah to point yourself
yeah my location
but that's what you mean
pretty much
roundabout okay explain that to me
I'm glad you want to take that an
inspector to the off-site works
you're seeking permission for that
outline
um oh you might need a microphone just
for everyone
that's right at the world roundabout
um the plan may be difficult for you to
find essentially appendix oh once again
the TN sorry constipation assessment PA
oh ta yeah okay
does that happen that happens
yes the reference number is a one sorry
you're talking about it
foreign
about
just a minor amendment to address some
slight capacity
a very minor Highway works well the
reference is CD
1.2.28
1.3.28 that's the transport assessment
and the appendices no doubt where the
plan is is 1.2.29 I think the appendix o
is 1.2 percent you know all dependencies
in quotes yeah yeah 1.2
the case
um
right so presumably that's something the
highway Authority one doing
um
transport statement of Common Ground
today which I have value right but it
also the initial assessments and the
desert navigation Works offered
exactly people saying conditioning these
sorts of work
I believe in just a section 278 I wear
improvements I think I think they are
but I'm I'm not planning actually it's a
grampian congression to require those
works if you don't have that plan
it will be delivered through a section
278 agreement which is an agreement with
the Iowa policy for The Works to be done
in my own way so but you'll see that
grumpy and conditioned subsequently
environment that's the contested highway
conditions but as I say only on the
details so this is referencing the
drawings to be approved and then you've
got a condition subsequently on
power and why
um
and for your reference in the County
Council statement of Common Ground
Section 3 bullet point 10 is the one
that confirms things are necessary
they're all conditioned to at the moment
is trying to do is to confirm the plans
okay
and if I thought the grampian conditions
do it without reference to that plan
would you go here absolutely yes
let's look at this
you could take the view that there are
a bit of doubling up
because you don't need to identify it as
an approved plan if you just inquiring
conditions tomorrow yeah okay you could
take the view that there's a bit of
doubling up with the location of the
access points because of Warranty Group
for finding is referred to when actually
they're all all of the access points are
on the indicative master plan anyway
thank you
yeah
the premises plan however is easily
important one I think
um it may be not within a separate
condition
um
yeah
okay
[Music]
um
hang on
accordance with the promises not more
that the reserve matters would come in
in accordance with the premises yes Mom
that this again is this contested
condition for you if you span your eye
down you will see that there is a
the the reason for the parameters plan
and again it's only contested because we
want to put some additional wording in
so if you wanted to do the same and take
it out of condition two and you can rely
on it in condition for subject to what
basically let's just say Okay
so there's no there's no dispute between
the two parties that the parameters plan
should form part of any running approval
and it's that references where it's
located yeah okay
so again if I took it out there but
there was a condition of being that the
reserve matters coming once we found
that yeah
well I mean I know you're the previous
that you like a list yeah it's just the
way I like things but um you know find
out your comments
the thing is
An approved plan is quite important
it's more
I would my thinking at this stage is a
parameter's plan is more to inform your
reserve batters and we have separate
conditions that's available what you
want to see you know as a batters and in
my experience a list of recruited
parents is not the place before that
because it's it's a separate condition
that's explaining what we want to know
is that matters I'm going to suggest
that some authorities I work in have it
as an informative list of the plans
okay all right
I assume you're happy for me to make a
judgment and then I will be you know you
can take me to the high court okay okay
if it helps the council to reference the
fans in the transport statement of
Common Ground the highway Authority list
themide and say that they
they listed the drawing numbers inside
the accessible to them
if it's just a case of referencing that
of what is acceptable you can find it
okay the fans will be in there they will
they will have a part to play for sure
our access fans right vacation plan and
our friends plans
okay
let's move on then um limitations on
development then so no more than 397
buildings yeah
ah so I see here now that condition 4
has been taken out because that's going
to be which is what we were talking
about because then it shall take place
in general yeah this is more what I was
thinking yeah so you want me to deal
with that now who's taking it out I need
to take it out uh so if you look at the
other schedule yeah mum the the
I'll go through each bit so it's agreed
between both parties the first sentence
the development shall take place in
general Conformity with and the
reference is the right reference yep um
the area the site identified on the
primates is playing those green belt run
shall be developed only for the
provision of attenuation the moment it
says ponds I wish to change that to
basins for the reasons that yeah said
um the subject to that
cycleways uh a cycle track and shall not
be used to accommodate any new buildings
or above ground structures that's all
agreed between the two parties
yes so the point then that we moved
through to
um which is the element in red what
we've put forward what I've put forward
um there because that overall
um plan that overall parameters plan
doesn't delineate within the area the
precise area of attenuation basins it's
it stretches across the whole of that or
that boundary then I'm asking for an
additional element of wording that says
no developmental commence until a plan
of the extent into the attenuation
basins in accordance with now if you
want to pull the plan up we can which is
the reference
n20005c that's the illustrative master
plan and that does delineate the area of
the basins and the reason I wanted to do
that is the last part of the
um
new sentence so the approved attenuation
basins within the green belt shall not
accommodate
Edwards building structures but
specifically put cuts and cycle tracks
so the first part of the condition
allows for cuts in cycle tracks because
they are either identified on the
council's plan a local plan or they
exist
but clearly you've heard my evidence
that said we will not be bringing those
into the attenuation basins so it's an
extra element to say what we won't be
doing
thank you does that make sense so
um
I think whether it's going to be public
or not you're saying not public we've
talked about whether to make it public
did that whatever the outcome of that is
will depend on whether there's the
liquid path and cycle traffic is that
right correct and and the if you go to
the end of that schedule if we're
dealing with us as well the only other
um conditioning dispute that's not
highways is shown on the other show
Jewels number 37
um and that's me bringing forward an
additional condition that basically says
boundary treatments for that area will
be submitted and improved so the tooling
together on the point that you've just
said if you believe that the public
can be encouraged or allowed into those
areas you'll probably strike out that
condition and you'll also strike out the
additionality if you don't then
um
I would suggest in
it should be brought in thank you
um and it was wrong person thank you
can we tie it down I think you made a
specific point
um that these boundary achievements
aren't going to be thanks to if they're
going to be Hedges and we tie that down
we can Mom yes um I think uh
conversation with the council we talked
to originally about about a more
specific type of
um enclosure and I think we took the
view we would defer that but if that's
part of your judgment that it should be
a drill then it's very important thing
to be precise about yeah
say something like
feelings for boundary achievement
s
comprising
Advantage treatments conclusion with
photos yeah
so that's 37 dealt with and I just yeah
put the counselors yeah
um we don't actually feel it's as a
necessary condition
um things like on smoking around
defeatings
um
the town since prediction is we can't
really see that it's we've been
following her requests
um that you know finally we went to the
public out of that area
and um the additional quality that it
I'm doing so might
be rise to open the designs
issues
um we feel it's better just not to have
the connection and to deal with all that
but it matches so yeah
so the council are actually in favor of
the public
being allowed in yeah
excited about the impact on the green
belt from that yeah
means
then Mom if you if you do
um grapple with this point for the
reasons it's being said condition 13
requires the details of the design of
the attenuation problems it doesn't
control the use so if you do believe
that the uses and a live element
um I won't go back over the evidence
then I don't believe there is a
condition that controls that which was
the point that was raised before of
obviously duplication I don't believe
that that is duplication and then it's a
judgment for you to take as to whether
it should be controlled or not and if so
of what nature yeah I think you're
taking me down rabbit holes um
let's just deal with the first point
about whether these rounds these ideas
could do with their matter
I think if it came down to I mean I'll
take it away to consider your point
um but I think the planning purpose
would be the green belt yeah wouldn't it
um
and it would be necessary I would have
thought to do without this stage but I
can take the points away
um
foreign
thank you
um
[Music]
I mean relying on the Promises plans to
tell us by being about land Facebook
so you could actually just have a
condition that said General Conformity
with the crown of the plan
and when something's definitely dealt
with the fact that in the green belt
there there would be no
um
we buildings were above ground level
structures associated with
completed generation Basin something
like that so I could split face
which is any objections about the same
it's just them
lumping them together sometimes can make
them less clear
and then the additional appointment
plans I've been for is
apparently the extent of it
transformation
it's simply man when you look at the
parameters plan
it doesn't go to the granular nature of
along that southern boundary where the
the edge of the attenuation basins will
be what we call as the foot Cuts either
side and therefore this condition
rightly says forecasts are acceptable in
the Greenville because they exist but
we're not proposing any new robots
so it was it was again that point
that within a certain subset of the
green belt area
I think the parent has plans there's
more
than just I mean it tells us a lot
because it tells us for housing he's
doing where roads are going so I think
that should be a discrete Point yes that
we want
anything to speak about more there is no
matter to be honest yes that's a great
mom I don't think there's a difference
between possible there are massive need
to be in general quality with a
parenting plan that's it
tell that one
um
we also want to make sure that the green
belt land
doesn't have any of the attenuation
basing buildings and so on because we
just stuff but so that's what matter I
think that's more discreet than just
about Reserve methods being in general
Conformity and then now we're talking
about we want to know
the extent of our attenuation basing and
the details of that so I think that's a
separate Point again or a certain
condition again
that we're asking for that to come
forward again I guess as part of our
Reserve matter yes
in the attenuation early what we call by
moving towels we're approval of what you
tell them
which is what you're proposing and and
that's either a yay or name yeah okay
so really you're saying yeah or what
we're looking for is it the third
matches we want to know exactly what
this contamination basing area is going
to be like yeah I don't mind because
it's the focus of this inquiry for the
same reasons Council talked about uh
plans we want to framework if your mind
is to approve this we want we want to be
clear on the framework when we bring
forward our Reserve matches rather than
leaving it absolutely open having gone
through all of this exercise
yeah I think that then your last
sentence is kind of repetition of
that other point isn't it just about the
green going back to the green bell and
not having structures in it it is Mom I
think the way you describe it in three
elements makes make sense I think the
middle element there will be no but
the first one deals with General
components with the chrometers the
middle element on Greenbelt says
there'll be no structures
um Etc I think what the council wanted
to bring in was the middle element had
put constant cycleways but that's just I
can deal with that because
um and hence the third element would say
yes no
thank you
I guess I just need to get my head
around whether the intonation basically
is expected probably is
um
that I can either say
that reserved matters should be imposed
to attending an ocean-based scenario or
as part of this outline commission we
wanted the attention by the way yeah
exactly just making sure we get that
right how we ask for that information
but it's agreed that we need that
information here
thank you okay sorry there's a lot to
impact I think on permission for at
least get my head around there thank you
I had multiple purposes
yes
okay stay condition five then
under conditioning recommended from
Yorkshire water about um the sewer
crossing the side between the North West
and corner of the site
uh similarly coal Authority with the
zones of influence we've got no build
zones
condition seven and you get phasing
um
eight
um goes to the instability evidence and
again is
recommended by the coal Authority as
part of their Consulting response with
them
okay
so that's from the Call of Duty yeah
the terminations but that's what we were
talking about yesterday yes well
standard Suites have conditions on
assessments what to do if you find
anything
archeology repaired about
um
what makes sense
so the surface water drainage which is
um 13 is the point you can see in C
details of the design of the attenuation
problems which is where it the potential
overlap might be but the wording is
around the design so clearly
so they both serve the same purpose
potentially
as you say my my concern was that that
relates to design not use so that comes
back to your point around
whether you
you have any truck with that point or
not so clearly the circle is more to
drainage it more than just the
attenuation Basin so this goes to that
scheme of all of those elements the
connection to Art broke
um rather than conducts condition for
where the C is strong enough in its own
right right so the surface water
drainage is about the whole site
drainage of the whole site and the
attenuation basins are part of that
which is what condition pattern was
doing but it's whether we want to be
even more secure in our International
basins because of the issues
for the green belt reasons rather than
the actual surface water you know
generation reasons
you have it here now
um well I mean people
um conditions
you don't need to elaborate on on
achievement like
so you're actually happy just making oh
you'll have a condition forwards today
yeah
okay
14 14 is a sort of tailpipe of 13 really
it's just making sure that everything is
being done okay
landscape and ecology management and
yes Mom that's um recommended by example
Wildlife trust and it's it's a fairly
standard list of
new elements required
some of this work already been done
when looking at equality
yes
and does anyone I mean sometimes get
traditions of this nature you can take
the detail out because they're kind of
looked at on a case-by-face basis and
just ask for the management plans
specific to this side did you have any
means like that
next one came from the console team and
we didn't have a problem with it rather
than it being a precise requirement of
the accountant I wish a wildlife Justin
foreign
[Music]
boxes
Hedgehog
holes
yes that's
um
the likelihood is not very development
will be delivered because
sorry there will be some communal sound
straight areas
um and then things is very well known
typically you know of course they were
actually delivering the housing so it
just to close off that and
see
that can it's as many development show
commence until you've got your landscape
and ecological management plan
so could you deal with that under there
how does within the housing phases of
the development what does that tell me
in that condition
designed
and it may have some a brain work or
what is happening in individual cases
but it's we're envisaging the the actual
housing will come in from you know doing
Windows different developers different
to reach different value and that their
in turn will have an obligation to be
some assorted
um biodiversity enhancing
and it was you can only capture that in
the soccer condition
s
within the housing phases of the
development
landscaping and biodiversity and not so
excited for the Bible before
participation with all of the government
now I don't think why that can't be
covered under the basket management plan
which covers timing
and
responsibilities
well I mean well not really I mean that
is just through that was the rationale
that is that the condition because it's
and researched Brooklyn house building
will be significance
but they might not have any influencer
being shared uh whereas that might
remember their control of the business
management
so we're just to make sure that the
housing uh doing housing developers are
going to change because I'm doing
um by identity income streams so how
does conditioning system do that
it's not working for science within the
housing value what is that
yeah well if I was the developer and I
was looking at that
I mean
within the housing phases
assuming there is phases
so I'm part of that causing phase
you wouldn't have produced
to make details
if that books and third boxes
I can't actually commence development
under condition 15 into life but are you
saying if one
development starts a phase
it works um
your leading condition to community you
say but in condition being having no
development of each phase or in
accordance with condition seven which is
the phasing condition
so if we link this back so that you're
right we don't have to do site wide
I think which is the sentiment that we
actually link this back to be delivered
on the phase the whole of 15 on a phase
basis linked to discharge of condition
seven then IT addresses the points
when you have a paid in condition which
we've just discussed
is that right
would work
um I mean it all depends on what comes
after the closing times theme so I was I
had in mind but
it there's quite often the case and
you'll see the housing has been
absolutely actual scriptural Landscaping
when you get respect the shared areas
that would burn things in its own right
and then we've got the order pages that
are actually video Bill housing
thought was that was my own results I
know how students do like to because you
know they're like when the point of view
of managing they deliver these
conditions
the right to say that it was exclusively
conviction relates to what they've got
to do as opposed to not really
um
maybe I'm being absolutely simplistic
but
I if you ask if the landscape and
ecological management pattern
and we wanted to cover the whole story
completely
and you've asked for that I want a
landscaping an ecological management
plan because it's all the green areas of
the bat boxes that I want to see on this
entire development and you can't start
developing until you've agreed that with
me and then I want to implement those
agreements it doesn't matter which page
or developer they have to
wait no surely
because they're not all going to start
at the same time so no but none of them
could start until the whole thing's
agreed but then the detail at the
individual phases
um right so you'll see
um
so is that the problem with what I'm
suggesting in that it's too big a site
to agree
I think I'm from from our perspective
the the phasing condition facing seven
allows us to do what you've said there
will be certain site enabling work
certain uh comprehensive site delivery
works that we will put in a phase and
then there'll be some places to bring
forward the housing look condition seven
requires us to work that out
um so that's that to me the issue is
resolved with condition seven and then
as you rightly say the condition 15 if
we add in any phase then the council
will have approved the phasing there
might be some site-wide elements there
might be some more site-specific
elements for tooling together and that's
how you bring forward these Lifestyles
so you essentially want a land gave an
ecological management plan with each
phase
um so essentially what we're talking
about Venus instead of a landscape and
ecological management plan for the whole
site we want one per phase yes thank you
and then that would resolve conditions
this theme okay
condition 17.
foreign
habitat
from an environmental point of view but
if you look at condition 34 there is the
green belt enhancement scheme that deals
with off-site
um improvements to Environmental Quality
and accessibility
so it whether
what is in addition what is 17 doing
that 34 isn't doing
the main thing that's screaming to me
about conditions 17 is if it will be
on land in the vicinity of the sights of
the South
where's that then
so we pinpoint that yes Mom so in uh in
the I'll find you a reference we've
identified the broad extent of that on a
plan uh under the ownership control of
harvest and we've identified those so
when we come back with the biodiversity
metric we've identified some of those
types of works so if I shall I find that
plan and give you a reference so well
that plan if there is a plan of this
plan that needs to be referenced can
that be dealt with by a condition if
it's not in the red line
under the control of the applicant right
is it is
financing
is this part of biodiversity Net game
yes ma'am there's this
diversity Net game drawing its appendix
score of
Mr Baker's
um
evidence but there is an accessibility
one record
and it's 16 which the World shows
evidence
I'm sure we need that
by the best thing yeah yeah
we haven't tied down the figures you
gave me
because we're at uh
outlying stage those elements have been
assumed and I think that you've heard
sometimes they get tied down so someone
makes a commitment to say 25
biodiversity again sometimes you see
them in legal agreements as well I think
um
but here it's just really saying
you know that might be a bit late
it's basically saying
you need to submit details of your
biodiversity Net game for approval which
is the over the page the second file
that's that's what it goes against the
deprometric yeah
the problem will make it more complex I
think the line is probably going to make
it more simple that's helpful that's
kind of what I'm trying to finish
you know if it's a requirements
biodiversity you know again
and what that episode yeah
we're already on to report early and so
yeah
okay the more you're based in detail the
more an impact you create there's other
little wrinkles for London yeah
see you is that right answer the phone
and that what we're looking for here is
details
of our private SBA
and is there a time where
we've occupied
or would you want it earlier
um
it doesn't necessarily need to come in
early
um
is it a problem that it's off-site it
being an ambition
uh not two hour
[Music]
and the land was only in Japan and
um the conditioning bites only before I
need one is offer card so the actual
thing that
please
the pointer which the condition you can
learn things he's laying the glowing
back and getting a chance to um inside
so um
just thinking out that what happens if
that land I don't know is sold
I'm no longer within their ownership
well
it's going without the registration
and there is that right
and that's what he's used right so
that's the land
yeah it's got a dateline man that's what
it is now right and he's got a little
development and what it would be and
that's how important things
so they're in scheme and that's the
Basin of the calculation
a little bit of the scheme which is
everyone's very early doors
because there's an outline applications
so yeah what we're actually asking
I think yeah it was entertained the
refinement of the team that already
they'll suggestion
[Music]
um
it's along the lines of
to
provide additional detail until
next one through
to make a statement
that's essentially what we're asking
sick of B because like habitat by the
rest of the enhancements in accordance
with
or in general accordingly recordings
Prince
yes
regardless of the moment's a good point
the whole document is upon this one
rather than continues and within that
there are then poor Planet Summers okay
so it's going to explore within the
economic Forum thank you that's include
Russian gold medals
um just for clarity were you also going
to delete the metric 3.1 and just put
the relevant metric
yeah probably
thank you
for the development yeah
okay I'll ask I think there's something
about that one
employment and training them into 19.
Islam it's a it's a standard condition
from the local authority to maximize the
delivery of the social benefits locally
okay
levels
position management
again yeah
let me see tree and hydro protection
all right
well Mr Moe's just reminded me that
perhaps for each phase would be helpful
in these
kinds of conditions back to phasing
again in the sidewalk but the tree and
hydro perfection
it was very soon
but Natalie is asking for is there a
massive are you saying there might be
different there's a different pages the
flexibility because of the amazing
condition that allows along with that
element
s
now it's probably cover it though
wouldn't it if you're doing your own
phase and you're doing this everywhere
that's right we would definitely tell
which you know relevant and
levels
feel Hydro perception then
not the Landscaping reserve my spirit
uh tree and hair dryer protection is
that a landscaping Reserve platter
yes
um
there was a matter of we'll just require
the details to come in I don't think we
enjoyed matches you know we're going so
far as to say you've got to put in your
details of someone helps them to touch
you so that needs to be as example of
conviction
okay I'll make a decision on that then
give on Facebook because it works
starting at
19.3 the next one which of the hour of
the wires
definitely
absolutely okay
but again that if you if there is a
reserved matter
then when you put in your reserve
Battlefield phase
immunity
in theory the council could put
conditions protect
these mergers
and the details of what you're going
through the type machine with the
implementation
okay
no development in any phase
until
the objectives
yeah
okay
a few more hours
into it isn't it exciting thing I do
like conditions right uh condition 21
then instruction management highways
County Council
okay
excellent thank you too it's also
um
County Council recommended a derivative
and I think we can this week Council of
other additional elements along those
highways
when I understand it
so I'm just trying to get my head around
21.
um no development should convince them
so details of measures for the avoidance
of death is water runoff from the site
in the construction page
and a time scale for implementation
of disability
details we've mentioned in going from
surface being to burn off
if it's water runoff
have we not dealt with surface water
from as I understand it from the site
onto the adopted highway but if you're
in the construction phase okay it's it's
good and construction management
facilities
site
during the construction campaign
so let's make this water run up onto the
highway correct if it's come from the
county and it's it's
a puppet highways
okay
I want you to make that a bit clearer
then
problems like German Construction
through construction everything
too you were saying structural
management plan
you need to yeah on any particular phase
but it's got things called sitting there
yes we can probably adopt for others
okay
instruction I should buy the reality
condition 10 for free
24 they removal of purchase trees of
shops they'll take questions after much
um
right are we into contested highways do
you want to put those to one side and
carry on through and deal with those at
the end okay yeah
standard information
therapy part of Reserve
has been of the founders organization
wise with them
because
they're Railway line again
yeah
we did have a representation from the
environmental health and with addiction
[Music]
um
I mean conditions just went into the
relationship
was it everyone's wearing latter
which was no matter which annoyancy
a very specifically
but if it's a problem we can even write
down now the outline stage yeah
um
[Music]
the roads that we're talking about green
line up and the one looking at Monster
Land or your garage lights yes
um but if it's taking me on that yeah
I can read the environmental health
consultation assuming that's somewhere
that can be found
amongst their constitutions okay
[Music]
Environmental Protection is 2.13 in
record documents there's three responses
listed there
so I said again 2.13 in the core
documents and there's three responses
sub elements to 2.13
thank you so that's where I'll find it
thank you okay Lighting in position 31.
unfortunately what no it's been a
detailed lighting should I do
yeah this is friendly enough one that
people sometimes argue is that is
because it comes on the layout but um
[Music]
but that's probably just an academic
point
the likely associated
because of ecology
is achieving good good environment
designs I think
original 32 thank you globals including
our areas
in details with flip classes
links that's kind of your green
interstate
they'll be a significantly with people
in writing yeah
that sounds good
um well the result matches though
specifically go into what's needed for
recreational boots is for example
why do there is the essential components
again because I was learning um
they could come in and part of him with
not as signature
the the coastal essential components it
was thought
it should feel a quick condition with
love
I think details of footpath cycle route
green spaces
it's going to be a reserve map under
layout and Landscaping
[Music]
um
and what detail you want you have that's
like your discretion that was a matter
stage yeah
but it doesn't mean your requirement
that is
say no
it's one of those parts have been here
if you wanted
to including the the United yes exactly
so what you can do outline is say when I
get a reserve massive I mean Landscaping
layout I would like to be deaf people a
bit more certainly so you can guide what
you want to see in them at this stage
but you can't necessarily tie it down if
it's reserved button
until
okay
travel time and information about space
yeah thank you
but it can't be tied down at this stage
no I mean quite talking with a scheme of
distance and you have a framework of
what you're in college it's amazing
objectives okay
[Music]
foreign
Ty
um
yes we need an implementation course
online
come up on the fourth and fifth lines
one to prove shall be implemented in
accordance with details and current book
timetable checked out there and put them
in the middle well yeah I see it moves
okay Commissioners for Greenbelt and
harvesting experience
well Mr walshaw's appendix 16
um is the Islamic you can see it there
it's the it's the other side of the
ecology that we've just said so it's
important what we might do within there
so it can have a in general Conformity
with that it's not got the detail
is that necessary
in the um the local fund policy
indicates that there there should be
um rebuilt outside Greenbelt
enhancements as part of the the involved
compensation issues in the allocation of
the sites in its first instance and
that's what we've learned today
so in the reason uh under this they can
sort of made reference to that policy
lc1 and the paragraph 5.27
okay
thank you
Landscaping
um
well planting to do the interfing is
this a reserved matter
um The Reserve matters through the
detail of it this condition is to uh
required
[Music]
okay
but when you get those details in you
can then put a condition on your other
battery
can you do it that way
um
well the outline connection is being
evolution
that matches all good conditions or
whatever
um
[Music]
address on that
okay
that's one of the natural housing
assistance
as well
right
inwards
we're gonna move on to highways mom yeah
but I was just being at condition 37. oh
well 37 it was an earlier iteration
um from me around that means of
enclosure that we we have superseded so
that's not all together they get it and
yeah for the reasons you've said it may
particularly yeah
yeah it's
no in terms of the next section on the
highways I I think the easiest way to do
this because we could use this table
that it's it's yeah it's it's helpful
but not perhaps totally helpful if you
have the transports aim to Common Ground
open which is CD 3.3.31
um I'm just a bit better
[Music]
maybe others do as well
um
I know you probably don't want to take
lunch because you probably wanted to
finish lunch
um
kind of review
how long do you think this would take
just make putting your points forward I
mean I know I'm the one taking the time
I think only about 20 minutes mum I
don't I don't think there's there's much
between us I think it's as you've just
gone through with everything else you'll
take a judgment on whether these are
implementable there's nothing of
substance it's yeah besides wording it's
24 25 26 27 28 29 yeah
everything else we've talked about yes
different points on each
or is this sort of an overriding theme
the overriding theme was the case
management conference you are still to
make sure we compressed as many
conditions into into fewer we went there
for to the County Council and said look
there's duplication here can we come up
with a more refined list which is which
is the appendix in the statement of
common ground right that's an agreed
list between us and the County Council
and I think what I would encourage now
is is always yeah that's where we start
and I think not here at the right-hand
side are are exactly the same but but
it's just the way we've set it up I'm
not sure it's as helpful so I think if
we start with well it's been the
statements of common ground and then and
then I think it was right to tell us why
they don't work
I think that's the that's the route
forward that I would suggest anyway
through
um there's an appendix sort of agreed
conversations with the highway Authority
and that's got what we and they
greet
and
we'll explore the extent and the reasons
for any disagreement from the local
environment
well I understand the common ground
I worries
and a bit assessment on the table that
you've got in front of you it's a
faithful reproduction of those words
from that appendix uh the the right hand
side of the table
I'm still packed out so many people in
three points I mean and what did you
just say to me nxp.com
with a bullet point before any other
operations yeah
designated condition each of those are
the conditions and suggests we just
after the top and work through if you
perhaps carry on okay
so we must think that we have transport
technical program because I agree with
the council with a County Council oh
with the kind of Highways okay so all
these are agreed by the County Council
of jurisdiction on highway on highways I
think the district council fishing bar
well yeah okay
have you had a chance to visit these
in the transport statement
um yes and uh as a result of looking at
the ASR did we draft for combinations as
they've gone across our Channel
foreign
[Music]
of what is
so you know in the table
Electronics live yeah but uh if you can
move through the Crossed Out Lines only
woman I want to speak conviction is you
know they wouldn't have black people
report
Ed
um and were crossed out because the
parent wanted to go back to the
conditions which they would agree with
the highway Authority relationship the
other word looking at this is
let's understand what they are one by
one experiment
so if I want your wording it yeah
right
what's
the big difference then between
the numbers all over
could I offer um
some information when you go to the
table
showing both versions of the contested
conditions there is a mapping uh there's
been a shift
the two elements you're looking at is
the transport statements have common
ground for hours in the County Council
and the struck out for the district
council those are the two things right
so
on 25 struck out and the first bullet
points what's the difference without
missing here going Everyone by reading
them
all right because we're struggling
support no transport certain so I'm just
working for your child again and I
assuming at the time now the congression
is starting with the coral and we will
go operations around commands
yeah yeah
um so it's just
um
yeah so it looks very smart as well I
mean the way I would normally start up a
condition like that would be before any
works
well then read lots of comments
you know the only truth it's on track
yeah so it seems to be the council's one
is more General
is more specific
um
well the repellents uh referring to
funds
you know me
um another that's already covered in
like newest uh plans condition
of the Chevrolet conditions is this the
discussion we had earlier
okay
[Music]
um
child was submitted to on the approved
in marching Bible a quick one and report
to that should be worded as shall have
been submitted to
um or being approved in right to
environment
what's an obligation on the planning
approaching to improve that
um what I was suggesting is pulling out
the green lane widening as a separate
condition that which depends everything
quality
[Music]
um
I mean the reason we put it together was
your direction it's not nice
English language
and I see just looks for the
highlighting authorities
thankfully I should start with that yeah
that's what we would suggest now which
is yet the same common ground that is
specific that's just what the hiring
code says okay the argument isn't with
you and you it's really the highway so
it's in the council which is we we have
simply aligned ourselves with the County
Council as the highway Authority and and
that's the evidence before you at the
inquiry and we say do you rely on press
the highway Authority conditions no no
no
there's no implementation
for example the first bullet point of
things that for the important conditions
following me
um it just says submitted to Improvement
by like planning foreign
comedy
foreign
[Music]
writing
um so what was your point right
well first it starts off before any
other operations of our commands next
we'll do anything necessarily any
necessary Dimension and cycling that
doesn't require any sense to you I think
that kid ruled if we may not prefer the
way
I've letters in it
um
but if we are going to work or when we
try and rely
before any operations are commenced
before that um I mean necessarily damage
and recyclers is there a problem
required to mental development
did you think
I can't yeah we just do that
well it depends on what occurred on the
very savings one that was all I was
trying to do this type of instrument of
anything
foreign
remove details to be selected
um
principle to me but is there an issue
about working
well
not specifically but I mean these two
tests anyway
um
so
if we're not doing the remote matches
then
um you'll do any of this condition you
know
will remove this conversation anyway
because we need this level of detail so
that's what you suggesting award
um
um that shall be submitted to be
approval writing because
um
challenging into shall have been
submitted to
have been approved in Russian guide work
on advantages
um implemented
as approved uh well not necessarily
implemented because
um
we don't know what's going to be
approval and Depends in advance
as regards the delivery reviews
um
somebody who's sitting here alone with
no one being Ableton
sorry this would be very incentive
you've got three episodes is
okay
invisibility sounds
and then something around me that sounds
good
the experts giving it and giving sorry
the the access to that phase
having
financing how about this I look at what
the county councilor said I looked at
what you said
Bridge Street is
um away from the science and kilometers
um
the worthy of the position in the state
of the Common Ground
is food stamps
before
when you're exploding
anything
and then simply it exists because
they're Improvement
um
framework
[Music]
uh that's one
okay
and they will move away from that which
we think watered it down
I'm really sorry I'm struggling to
concentrate yeah
yeah this is the thing I can't hear what
you're saying
no let's let's have a break
very hard looking at words that are
crossed down as well yeah okay
um but I'm happy to take it away
today and I've got a long journey home
and
I references this family has just helped
me by printing out
the councils highways conditions without
the crossing area yeah it's exactly the
same taking across the aerofile
yeah that would be great
I'm just wondering why there's a travel
plan
that's simply because it came from the
County Council it is exactly the same as
the one you've just commented on so
there is thank you
thank you kids
stay back
the county councils depending you know
anything that's available to Common
Ground yeah
those are the differences
there may be some points of
implementation that need to be worked
into the counties
um but I'm I'm very clear that it wasn't
relating to Bridge Street
Works which is 27 27.
in in the in the version that's appended
to the statement in common ground I'm
very clear that that works
the match is the language of the
framework
and gives the county what they want
which includes the Improvement in the
adopted Highway and Into The Pedestrian
Crossing
thank you
yeah I think why yeah
and
yeah goodness an easy guy has turned
into a difficult one it was uh I'm not
really difficult the last day
unless it doesn't rain yeah
okay
um is there anything else you need to
talk about then
no thank you no I don't think so we've
got something extensive for tomorrow at
two o'clock obviously for closing so
we're not at so if something comes up we
can raise it tomorrow so we're not
closing right
um
we've got a timetable for 106. we've got
a timetable but there's still confined
yeah particularly with you
um
it's possible
um that if we need to have a quick chat
on the conditioning tomorrow yeah
I would nearly spent that you know I
nearly said I might look at these
conditions tonight but you know if I'm
getting home at seven eight o'clock yeah
I I can't even you know
honestly half terms I just have a tiny
round to that halftones and children
it's Easter holiday next week so I
booked next week like a village of
mother
um but on a Friday the school was
shutting at half quarter cost one and
there's this in the morning so I really
should have taken another day off it was
like to creep out through them so I
envisaged quite openly busy and it's my
son's birthday today which I've
mentioned his 11th birthday so I'm very
eager to get home and say happy Joe
Thanksgiving rather than meet conditions
happy birthday
anyway that's a lot of them context you
didn't need to know but that's why I
might not I think we've made good
progress to a point and I think you do
need a sort of
um a sort of slightly
step away from it for a little bit have
a look at it tomorrow morning but then
we've got some chance to have a
discussion if any points yeah if you
want to discuss them I think with
conditions if things you know I need to
go away and have a look at what you've
all said there's a lot there
um I need to work out what the Russian
is if it comes to it I would be applying
and um if that happens and there's still
questions I can always invite out to you
both
yes not uncommon and you're welcome to
actually rather than have a a
misunderstanding yeah
um yeah I thought you're gonna say you
could read your conditions
when you do this
normally yeah but I'm quite a long way
away from here so I'd rather than not
come back because if possible I mean
yeah I always can come back to a site
visit but um
to be honest I need a site visit not
looking at more documents per day okay
right let's
um adjourn them for today
um and I will be all online tomorrow at
two o'clock